we're cracking down on sexual harassment
finally that's good you know gets
sexually harassed more than women the
one group
pets yeah nobody ever gets consent from
a dog
nobody people just pick it up kiss it on
the face rub its belly to that weird
creepy long pet where you grab the tail
at the end
we're creepy as hell with dogs and we
sound like creeps they like it they're
begging me for it yeah
thank god dogs can't talk we'd all go to
jail right
just some chihuahua in a courtroom like
percy flipped me over
then he caressed all eight of my nipples
then he slapped me on the ass repeatedly
and said you're a good girl good girl
oh god we harass dogs all day long and
they're appropriate harassing they can't
talk so they'll never report you that's
why they're man's best friend
also dogs forget stuff after like two
seconds you can stick your finger up a
dog's ass be like well that was weird
frisbee
[Applause]
[Music]
but my favorite my favorite are the
animal
facts the animal facts are just i think
incredible
this is from a website called devon
jen's
world of knowledge okay and i want you
to think about the people who put this
up okay
that you know not just the fact but who
did it and why they did it
what were they thinking okay number one
you can lead a cow upstairs but not down
thanks very much um
i looked into that it's true a cow will
go upstairs but they won't go downstairs
because the way their joints
don't oppose but i think of the poor
bastard who found out the hard way
come on daisy down you go i don't go
downstairs
come on no i don't go downstairs i'm
away with joy i don't care about your
joints
my wife's coming home from work in five
[ __ ] minutes get down the stairs
[Applause]
number two stroking a spider
can cause it to go bald
thanks one what sort of maniac goes
around stroking spiders
dracula's assistant i don't know
two is that a problem in the arachnid
world
premature building do they worry about
that much i thought
they'd be loving it wouldn't that be in
a skitted they're so [ __ ] hard
got all the legs all the eyes and the
teeth [ __ ] it i'm bored who cares
adds to it i like it more yeah
but no apparently it's a big big problem
you stroke a little spider
he goes oh my god he runs back to the
web and all the other spiders go
what are you wearing a baseball cap for
[Applause]
fashion
[Laughter]
bit weird no it's just fashion
we'll take it off in the web now i'll
just i'll just keep it on
a bit cold cold
we're in a cupboard under the sink it's
boiling
ah take it off now take it off oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
have you been in a human stroke here
leave this [ __ ] web
number three
polar bears will sometimes cover their
black nose during a hunt
to camouflage themselves more completely
it's a good idea in it because uh apart
from the old nose a perfectly
camouflaged there white snow's white
so sneaking up on little arctic hair
and i get there in the arctic hair he
turns round
polo there goes
[Applause]
but how did they find out because that's
behavioral
all the polar bears sitting around one
night going i'm starving
every time i sneak up in a little hair
he looks round and he hops off it's like
he can
see me i can't work out little voice
little hair goes i can tell you
can you see us well i can see where you
are and how many there are
of you really
how
kick yourself
now go on tell us
your nose is black the nose it's black
oh
[Laughter]
cheers
can you see us now no
thank you oh
crocodile hunter i give him i give him a
lot of love a lot of credit but you know
people go
he's such a loss to the nature community
you know
he taught us so much about nature
and i got mad when i heard this lady on
tv saying that he taught us a lot about
nature and it was like no he didn't
really teach a lot about nature
if you want to learn about nature you
watch discovery channel or one of these
you know nature programs where they have
a guy on safari and he's studying from
afar crocodile hunter and all come on
every episode
hey all you doing look over there
right there it's a tiger
and tiger weighs 800 pounds and it could
kill a man in 10 seconds
i'm gonna touch it
[Applause]
next episode that's a king cobra the
most venomous snorkeling all the planet
one boy now i'm dead i'm gonna pick it
up
he's angry
if he really wanted people to think he
was out there man america we should have
borrowed him
and sent him to iraq with no gun just a
camera crew
you imagine how bad that would have
freaked out the enemy you know you're
freaking a soldier working for al qaeda
and you're out there you know oh
[Music]
and he's walking up to him aye look over
there
[Applause]
it's an arcade remember an
iraqi soldier one of the most dangerous
creatures in all the planet
one push of a button and i'm gone
i'm gonna poke him with a stick
angry